getright was the craziest sprayer who
ever lived I want you to actually watch
this this is the getright
signature this is the kind of he would
do bro it literally became a meme that
if you just helding left click and just
went crazy and killed three people it
was a get right spread people were
genuinely afraid of him and in early CSG
go had continued like he was absolutely
crazy what aing oh my God this is one of
the craziest carright sprays in in
history so he starts spraying right
about now he's missing shots and then so
he starts tapping tapping bro the guy
was the spray Whisperer he would do like
this
watch and then just diffuse cuz he knows
the guys across the map he would like
move and jump and strafe while he Wasing
spraying sometimes he'd be really
precise and other times he would just be
an absolute memester and you never knew
which one you were going to get the guy
was a [__] Jedi